[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في كل مكان اهلا بكم الى حلقه
جديده من برنامج من واشنطن تاتيكم هذا
الاسبوع من مدينه ويستام بيتش حيث يقيم
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب رسميا منذ
خروجه من البيت الابيض في اعقاب انتخابات
2020 التي لم يتوقف ترامب عن وصفها
بالمزوره حلقه هذا الاسبوع تاتيكم من هذا
الموقع المطل على مياه هادئه تفصل هذه
الجهه من المدينه عن مارالاجو حيث يسكن
ترامب بعيدا عن صخب معقله السابق مدينه
نيويورك التي لم تتوقف عن قضي مضجعه ماليا
وسياسيا وكذلك قضائيا
المدعى عليه قدم 34 افاده زائفه لاخفاء
جرائم اخرى وتلك جرائم جنائيه في ولايه
نيويورك بغض النظر عن من تكون لا يمكننا
ولن نقوم بتطبيع السلوك الاجرامي الخطير
المدعى عليه قدم افادات زائفه بشكل متكرر
في وثائق الشركات في نيويورك وتسبب ايضا
بتقديم اخرين افادات زائفه
سيكون معي خلال هذه الحلقه براين كراولي
الكاتب والمعلق السياسي المختص في الشان
الامريكي
فلوريدا التي توصف بولايه الشمس المشرقه
هي احدى الولايات التي حصنها الجمهوريون
سياسيا لصالحهم منذ فوز ترامب بها في
انتخابات 2016
وبينما تنعم الولايه بطبيعه خلابه وسماء
زرقاء في معظم الاوقات الى انها لم تكن
دائما محصنه ضد العواصف السياسيه عبر
تاريخها السياسي القديم وكذلك الحديث
موجات من المهاجرين الكوبيين ايام الزعيم
الكوبي الراحل فيدال كاسترو مثلا مازق
انتخابات عام 2000 بين المرشحين الرئاسيين
الجمهوري جورج بوش الابن والديمقراطي
الجور والان قضيه دونالد ترامب الذي تحصن
موقعه ولو مؤقتا كما يقال عند الجمهوريين
في الولايه بعد موتونه في محكمه نيويورك
حيث وجهت اليه 34 تهمه جنائيه
اعتقد ان ما يفعلونه بهذا الرجل امر مقرف
ومروع انه يقاتل من اجلنا ولن يتركه وحده
انها 34 جنايه هذا لا يصدق اعني انه جنون
انا من فيلادلفيا واسوا المجرمين في
شوارعها لا توجه لهم جنايه واحده بينما
وجهوا للترامب 34 جنايه لا اصدق ذلك انا
مصدومه حقا
لقد كانت التهمه التي سمعناها مزيفه ولا
تتضمن جنايه الامر برمته مضحك وبعد ذلك
يحاولون ربط التحويلات بتمويل الحملات
الانتخابيه وهي لم تاتي منها وفوق كل ذلك
سقطت جميعها بحكم قوانين التقادم لذا هذه
الاتهامات سخيفه ولا يعتبر اي منها جنايه
على مستوى الولايه قد
تكون لكن لا اعتقد انها كذلك ايضا
الدعم الجمهوري
ترامب فيتش ومناطق اخرى في ولايه فلوريدا
يمثل مازق لحاكم الولايه الجمهوري رن
ديسانتس الذي اصبح نجما سياسيا عند بعض
شرائح الجمهوريين خاصه منذ انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونجرس في نهايه العام
الماضي وكانت تلك الشرائح تتطلع لان يصبح
ديسانطيس هو مرشح الحزب الجمهوري في
رئاسيات 2024
اما ترامب فكان قد فقد جزءا كبيرا من
بريقه وسطوته على الحزب بعد ان فشل عدد من
المرشحين الذين دعمهم ترامب في الوصول الى
الكونجرس مما اعطى الحزب اغلبيه هزيله في
مجلس النواب وحاله دون سيطرته على مجلس
الشيوخ
ولكن اذا كانت محاكمه ترامب في نيويورك قد
عززت اسهمه الانتخابيه وله مؤقتا كما يقال
فان ذلك جاء مصحوبا بدخوله التاريخ
السياسي الامريكي مره اخرى ولكن هذه المره
كاول رئيس سابق توجه اليه تهم جنائيه
ترامب نفتلك التهم وهاجم النظام القضائي
الامريكي برمته بسببها
نظامنا القضائي اصبح خارج القانون انهم
يستخدمونه الان كما كل شيء اخر للفوز
بالانتخابات
كان ذلك الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب وقد
تحدث بوعيده عودته من نيويورك الى
عودته من نيويورك حيث كما هو معروف مثل
امام محكمه هناك حيث وجهت له
34 تهمه
ارحب مجددا براين كراولي الكاتب والمعلق
السياسي المختص في الشان الامريكي معي هنا
في
براين مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن شكرا
بدايه يعني هذه التصورات في الايام
القليله الماضيه ماذا تعني لاهميه ولايه
فلوريدا في المشهد الانتخابي الامريكي
اولا اود ان ارحب بكم في فلوريدا المشمسه
بالرغم من
قوه ارياح يسرني وجودكم معنا كذلك سوف
اعطيكم خبرا عاجلا حصل في دقائق الاخيره
وهو مهم بالنسبه الى الحمله الانتخابيه
الرئاسيه
بايرن احد اعضاء الكونجرس الذين توقعوا
كثيرا ان يدعم
منذ دقائق انه يدعم ترامب في للرئاسه وهذا
سوف يثير موجه صاخبه في المشهد السياسي في
فلوريدا
اعتقد
اننا بدانا نشهد
موجه تغيير داخل حزب الجمهوري في فلوريدا
وعلى مستوى الدوله بكاملها كثر كانوا
يعتبرون ان روند سانتوس قبل اسابيع سوف
يتفوق على دونالد ترامب في الانتخابات
المقبله ولكن الان يبدو لنا ان دونالد
ترامب هو الذي سوف يعود الى المشهد
السياسي
السؤال بالنسبه لروند سانتوس وغيره هي
بالنسبه للمرشحين في الحجم الجمهوري هو هل
يسيطر مكانون من التصدي لهذه الموجه
ترامبيا ام ان هذا فقط مؤقت
عطفا عليه يعني من الان حتى
مرحله تحديد الحزب الجمهوري لمرشحه
النهائي الذي سيخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
عام 24 ومن الان حتى موعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام
بكم تقيس اليوم الانتخابي في الولايات
المتحده تقيسه بيوم باسبوع هل تقيس اليوم
بسنه هل تقيس اليوم بقرن كما يقال احيانا
في الرزنامه الانتخابيه الامريكيه يوم
يعادل سنه
اذا احسنت فهم السؤال فعلا سوف اعطيكم
لمحه تاريخيه سريعه عن فلوريدا والحزب
الجمهوري فيها
شاهدنا فيها حاكما ديمقراطيا كانت في
العام 94 ومن ثم جاب بوش وهو نجل الرئيس
الامريكي السابق جورج فاز في العام ثمانيه
وتسعين ومنذ تلك اللحظه شاهدنا تغييرا
كبيرا في ديناميكيات السياسه في فلوريدا
بحيث انه للمره الاولى هذه السنه لدينا
500 الف
ناخب جمهوريه
اضافي سجل لطالما كانت هذه الولايه يسيطر
عليها الديمقراطيون ولكنها تشهد تغيرا
السبب في هذا تغيره هو الياس والشعور
باننا سئمنا جائحه كورونا
والاقفال التام بالاضافه الى الوضع
الاقتصادي اين الكثير من الولايات الاخرى
تقفل فيها المؤسسات وتاتي الى فلوريدا
وكان هناك
غضب كبير تجاه التصرف الحكومي وسلوك
الحكومي مع جائحه كورونا وقد شاهدنا ذلك
في الولايه وعلى مستوى ولايات اخرى ايضا
انما يعني السؤال الذي يطرح هو انه
المسافه الزمنيه التي تفصل هذا الوقت عن
انتخابات 24
ممكن ان تحدث فيها الكثير من المتغيرات
والفتره التي تفصل هذه المرحله عن
انتخابات 24 هناك ملاحقات قضائيه اخرى
يتوقع ان يخضع لها
هل معنى ذلك ان مصير ديسانتس لم يحسم بعد
رغم
ارتفاع اسهم دونالد ترامب المرحله مباشره
بعد محاكمه نيويورك
هذه كلها امور غير معروفه وان ندخل هذه
الدوره الانتخابيه في عام 2024
لدينا عدد من التهم الاخرى التي قد توجه
الى دونالد ترامب وهذا يخلق وضعا لراند
سانتوس
باعتباره شخصا كان يظهر ويصنع نجمه اكثر
ولكن الان صار السؤال هل يمكن ان يستمر
كذلك وان
يجتذب المزيد من الداعمين والناخبين لدينا
اول اختبار انتخابي بعد
فتره غير
طويله كان روند سانتوس
يعتمد ليس فقط على الفوز بترشح ولكن ايضا
على اقناع الناخبين
الجمهوريين
باننا قد سئمنا هذه الدراما ترامبيه حتى
من يدعم ترامب بدا يتعب منه ولكن الان نرى
الكثير من الاشخاص الذين يعودون لدعم
ترامب وسوف يصعب على روندا سانتوس ان
يستمر في شعبيته وان يقنع الناس بانه
يمكنه ان يمضي قدما في 204 وعشرين هناك
الكثير من الاشياء التي سوف تستجد مع
توجيه الدهم في الاشهر المقبله
وهذه لعبه مفتوحه
يعني ما حجم المعضله التي تعتقد انت ان
ديسان يواجهها في اعقاب محاكمه ترامب في
نيويورك من حيث انه بطبيعه الحال قال انه
ضد المحاكمه وانها مسيسه كما يقول بقيه
الجمهوريين ولكن من جهه اخرى بالنسبه له
اذا ترشح ديسان سيكون هو المنافس الرئيسي
وبالتالي عليه ان يسعى
لتحطيم اسهم دونالد ترامب عند الناخبين
الجمهوريين ما حجم المعضل التي يواجهها
المشكله التي يواجهها ديسان تسمع ترامب
حاليا
هي ان
دعنا لا يراه فقط على انه خصم بل صارت
مساله شخصيه يشعر بانه هو الذي ساعد في
ايصال الى منصب الحاكم وسانتوس
خانه لمجرد انه فكر بالترشح للرئاسه
المعلوم حين بدات تظهر اولى المعلومات
بنسبه الى توجيهها كانت اول ملاحظات راندا
يقول انه لم يكن
[موسيقى]
متورطا مع تلك الممثله الاباحيه وهذا كانت
بعد ذلك خرج روندا سانتوس بتصريحات اقوى
ولكن بعد ذلك توقف عن الحديث وترام سوف لن
ينسى ذلك وسوف يريد الانتقام
اذا امكن ان نعرف سريعنا على قضيه ليست في
جوهر الموضوع الان انما للنظام السياسي
الامريكي له حقائقه ووقائعه وغرائبه ايضا
من ضمن تلك الغرائب ان دي سانتيس كان قد
قال انه لن يقبل ان يسلم دون درامب الى
نيويورك يعني في العرف الدولي التسليم
يكون بين دوله ودوله اخرى في العرف الذي
تحدث عنه ديسانتيس يتحدث عن التسليم من
ولايه الى ولايه اخرى يعني ما طبيعه او ما
حقيقه هذا الموقف الذي تحدث عنه تسليم
حصل في نيويورك او ما يحصل في نيويورك قد
يؤذيه في الانتخابات يجب ان يفوز
بالانتخابات الاوليه المصغره داخل الولايه
اولا واي ظهور له بموقف ضعيف سوف يكون
بمثابه خيانه لترامب عدم ظهوره عدمته لما
حصل في نيويورك وادانته للنائب العام في
نيويورك سوف يجعل الكثير من الجمهوريين
يعتبرون ان راندا سانتوس ليس معنا
تحدث عن التسليم اكستراديشن
التسليم فقط كان فعلا موضوعا سخيفا لا
خيار امام الحاكم سوى ان يسلم ترامب اذا
كان ذلك ضروريا ولكنها كانت نقطه سياسيه
جيده منها لكي يظهر انه من جهه يدافع عن
الرئيس
وكل مره
تتصلن له فرصه انتقاد ما يحصل في نيويورك
لا يوفر هذه الفرصه وبالتالي القول
نيويورك سوف لن اسلم دونالد ترامب لم تكن
مثلا مرتبطه بل كانت مرتبطه بكونها صفعه
لنيويورك التي يعتبرها ولايه ترتكب الكثير
من الجرائم التي تودي بالبلاد
تحملني في مطلع البرنامج كان يفترض ان
نتحدث الى مراسل الجزيره في وسط مدينه
بامبيتش تعذر الاتصال به في ذلك الوقت
انما يبدو انه تم ربط الاتصال به ساعود
اليك بعد قليل ناصر مرحبا بك في برنامج من
واشنطن يعني لم يعلن ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه حتى الان لكن ما حجم المشكله
الانتخابيه التي قد يواجهها ان قرر ترشيح
نفسه في ظل ما حصل مع دونالد ترامب بناء
على تجربتك مع الناخبين هنا في فلوريدا
حاكم ولايه فلوريدا نجم حقيقي بالمقياس
السياسي على المستوى المحلي فلوريدا ليس
باقي الولايات المتحده نجم الحقيقي شاب في
مجال السياسه الكل يعترف انه في البدايه
لكن اعطى نتائج جيده بالنسبه للاقتصاد
المحلي نسبه الرضا عن ان اتصل عبد الرحيم
لتسعه وخمسين بالمئه لكن مشاعره واماله ان
يسعى يوما ما الى البيت الابيض هنا يبدا
المشكل داخل الحزب الجمهوري الان دسنت
تقوى بشكل ان حمله الرئيس ترامب منذ هذا
الصباح بدات الان تحاول اقناع داعمي داخل
ولايه فلوريدا المانحون الماليون بالتحول
عنه والى العوده الى ترامب العوده الى
الاصل ان صح التعبير وبالتالي داخل الحزب
ديسانتس لديه تلك الاعمال في نجوميه في
الوصول بيت الابيض لكنه يواجه حائطا
سياسيا او وحشا سياسيا يدعى دونالد ترامب
على مستوى الحزب لنقل انه يملك الحزب
الجمهوري واذا كنت الان
او
حتى مايك بانس وتفكر في الترشح يجب ان
تفكر مرتين لنا الحزب يميل في هذه الاثناء
يميل نحو شخصيه
وكثيرون ممن صوت
دعم بداوا يتراجعون حسب التقارير اعلاميه
محليه ويعودون الى الاصل الى شخصيه
عبد الرحيم التالي الحزب لديه هذه المشكله
الى حد ما طالما يده تسيطر ويبدو انه
يسيطر جمع عشره ملايين دولار خلال خمسه
ايام يمكن تتصور ماذا ستكون عليه شكل
الحمله ترامب في الايام القليله المقبله
مفهوم ناصر
يعني انت ذكرت الان وصف دونالد ترامب
بالوحش السياسي هذا بطبيعه الحال العديد
من الامريكيين يصفونه بهذا الوصف السياسي
يعني عطفا عليه هل تعاطف الجمهوريين كما
يقال حاليا في فلوريدا مع دونالد ترامب
مرده الى انهم فعلا يؤمنون بانه هو الطريق
الصحيح الى الرفاهيه في الولايات المتحده
ام ان امتعاضهم من مساله المحاكمه راجع
الى خوفهم من انه اذا كان
الرئيس السابق
وصاحب النفوذ المالي والسياسي قد حكم او
قد وجهت اليه تهم جنائيه فما بالك
بالمواطن العادي الذي ليست ليس لدي هذه
هذا النفود يعني ما مصدر هذا الدعم الشعبي
في فلوريدا كما يقال لدون
كل العوامل التي ذكرتها عبد الرحيم هي
بالفعل تشرح هذه الشخصيه لكن في الحقيقه
وكما يراه اعدائه ربما اصح لي ان اعود
للوصف الذي يعطيه الليبراليون
الديمقراطيون للشخصيه الشخصيه
بامتياز ليس سياسيا وراءه ايديولوجيا
وانما رجل يحسن
الانتهازيه السياسيه وقد شخصين وقفت على
الكثير من مظاهر هذا النوع من التوظيف
السياسي للخطاب لدى الرئيس ترامب هنا في
فلوريدا من عمال المطارات سائقي التاكسي
مثلا اتحدث اليهم هنا وهناك من داعمي
ترامب كانوا يفكرون ربما في لحظه ستقضي
على ذلك الوحش لا خرج قويا قيل لي هنا من
العديد بان ترامب مازال يحكم امريكا لم
نخسر الانتخابات بل قيل ايضا ان ايضا لا
يحكم هناك شخص اخر يحمل قناعا فعقليه
والشعبويه والتضليل السياسي الذي يمارسه
السيد ترامب حتى الان حتى هذه اللحظه مع
ماجا يجعلوا امريكا عظيمه تعطيه بالفعل
تلك القوه الشعبيه وصدقني عبد الرحيم هناك
الالاف بل الاملايين الامريكيين مستعدون
لسماع هذا النوع من الخطاب انا الضحيه
الدوله العميقه
الحكومه الفيدراليه الضرائب الجريمه الى
اخره بالتالي الاسباب جاهزون مع الاطراف
الان الى ان يستثمر مجددا وكثيرون هنا
يريدون ان يكون رئيسا
شكرا ناصر شكرا جزيلا لك ناصر انضممت الي
من وسط مدينه بام بيتش وكما سمعنا بطبيعه
الحال هناك العديد من انصار دون ترامب
الذين يعتقدون انه لا يضللهم بل يعتقدون
ان بيض هو الذي يضللهم وان ترامب ليس
ديماغوجي بل يخدم مصالحهم مصالح هذه
الشرائح التي تحدث عنها ناصر حسيني في
مداخلته يتميز عن رؤساء امريكيين سابقين
بكونه قد وجهت اليه تهم جنائيه كرئيس سابق
بعد ان كان قد حكم برلمانيا مرتين خلال
رئاسته تطورات تعيد الامريكيين الى سيره
رؤساء كديمقراطي بالكلينتون في قضيه
في فضيحه
قبل فصل دانه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في قضيه
وعلاقه ذلك بانتخابات 2016
عاش الامريكيون مخاضات عسيره سابقه كمخاضم
محاكمه ترامب برلماني في الكونجرس حيث سعد
الديمقراطيون لعزله في قضيه اوكرانيا
وكما هو اليوم في قضيه دانيلز ظلت ترامب
ينفي التهم الموجهه اليه بلا هوادا
المحاكمه البرلمانيه مزحه كبرى واصبحت
مثارا للضحك حول العالم لم ارتكب ايه
مخالفه واتهمتان المعنيتان ليستا جادتين
ولا تشكلان جريمه لقد صوتت الاغلبيه
الساحقه من الجمهوريين لتبرئه ولم يكن من
المفترض ان يكون هذا شانا حزبيا لم يرد
الاباء المؤسسون ذلك ولكنه تحول الى شان
حزبي ومزحه ومحاوله للملاحقه السياسيه في
تسعينيات القرن الماضي خضر رئيس
الديمقراطي الاسبق بالكليندن حربا دروس
لافشال محاولات عزله في قضيه
مونيكالوينسكي ذائعه الصيد كلينتن حسب
العديد من الامريكيين خرج جريحا من تلك
الحرب لكن سحر الجمهوريين انقلب عليهم
فخسروا في الانتخابات اللاحقه وتقلصت
مقاعدهم في الكونجرس مساء الخير هذا
المساء في هذه الغرفه وعلى هذا الكرسي
ادليت بشهاده امام مكتب المحقق المستقل
وامام هيئه المحلفين الكبرى اجبت على
اسئلتهم بصدق ومن بينها اسئله تمس حياه
الشخصيه اسئله لا يود اي مواطن امريكي
الاجابه عنها وايضا يجب ان اتحمل
المسؤوليه الكامله عن كافه افعالي في
الشان العام والخاص قبل كلينتون بحوالي
عقدين حكم رئيس حلت به قامه كبرى الرئيس
الجمهوري ريتشارد نيكسون
لقد اصبح من الواضح لي انه لم يعد لدي
قاعده سياسيه قويه بالقدر الكافي في
الكونجرس لتبرير المواصله
شعرت بشده انه من الضروري ان نشهد
الاجراءات الدستوريه حتى النهايه طالما
كانت هناك قاعده كهذه
لذلك ساستقيل من منصب الرئاسه
ظهر الغد
نيكسون استبق عزله بتقديم استقالته من
الرئاسه تجنبا لما كان سيصاحب قرار العزل
من مذله كما ان استقالته جاءت نتيجه لتخلي
الجمهوريين عن دعمه بعد ان ثبت تستره على
قرار التجسس على الديمقراطيين في مبنى
معلم تاريخي وشم الفضيحه في الذاكره
السياسيه الامريكيه
وعطفا عليه كنت في وقت سابق قد تحدثت الى
المؤرخ الرئاسي جيم روبنولت
مرحبا بك في برنامج من واشنطن يعني مثل
هذه القضايا التي نتحدث عنها في موضوع
دونت درامب يبدو انها متجذره في التاريخ
السياسي الامريكي الرئيس التاسع والعشرون
مثلا كانت له علاقات جنسيه مع سيدتين
في عشرينيات القرن الماضي يعني كيف تعتقد
ان ذلك قد اثر على وضعه السياسي مقارنه
بما نشهده اليوم مع دونالد ترامب
كتبت مقالا في الواشنطن بوس في نهايه هذا
الاسبوع اعتمادا على كتابه قضيه هارلينج
الحب والسياسه ايام الحرب العظمى
29 للولايات المتحده وبدا رئاسته قبيل
الحرب العالميه الاولى وكان لديه مشكلتان
كان في حياته امراتان كان عليه ان يدفع
لهما لقاء سكوتهما خلال حملته الانتخابيه
واثناء رئاسته كانت الاولى تحت المراقبه
كجاسوسه المانيه محتمله خلال الحرب
العالميه الاولى هنا في الولايات المتحده
كانت الثانيه اصغر عمره من الاولى وقد
انجبت له طفله وكانت الاثنتان بحاجه الى
المال لقاء سكوتهما خلال الحمله
الانتخابيه وهذا شبيه بما قام به دونالد
ترامب مع
اذا قارنت قضيه
مع السيده احدى السيدتين وكانت تتهم بانها
كانت جاسوسه لالمانيا في ذلك الوقت اذا
قارنت ذلك بالوضع الحالي لرام مع ستورمي
دانيلز
بتصورك يعني اي القضيتين تثير الراي العام
الامريكي اكثر
هذا سؤال جيد وفي نظره في قصه هاردينج
امراه كان على علاقه بها مده 15 عاما كان
بينهما علاقه طويله الامد وفي تلك العلاقه
كان هناك ما يتابع تلك المراه من مكتب
المدعي العام على اعتبار انها جاسوس
المانيه محتمله وكان هذا اكثر خطرا على
البلاد من حيث ما كان يمكنها القيام به او
ابتزاز هاردين ايضا كان هذا وضعا اكثر
خطوره ولكن وعندما دفع لها هاردينج
المقابل سكوتها لم يخرق قوانين انتخابيه
فلم يكن يفرق قانون عندما دفع لها المال
ولم يقترف اي خطا في نظري لقد حاولت معه
الا يعطي صوته لدخول الولايات المتحده في
الحرب ولكنه صوت لصالح الدخول في الحرب
كان هذا وضعا اكثر خطوره ولكن الوضع
الحالي اسهل في اعتباره جريمه عملا
بالقوانين الانتخابيه المعمول بها اليوم
واعتقد ان ما يجري اليوم هو امر هام
للرئاسه الامريكيه والدونل ترامب
كما معروف في قضيه مونيكا كان قد اعرب عن
شعوره بال
ذنب يعني كيف تقيم انت هذا الامر الاعراب
عن الشعور بالذنب وتجليات ذلك في مثل هذه
القضايا
للرؤساء الامريكيين عبر التاريخ السياسي
الامريكي
هذا سؤال جيد اخر في نظامنا القضائي عندما
يقوم المدعي العام باعتقال فرد لقيامه
بجريمه يحاول المدعي العام الحصول على
تعاون المتهم بغيه الحد من الاضرار
الناجمه عن الجرم وفي حال حصول هذا
التعاون فسيضع المدعي العام ذلك في علم
القاضي عندما يقوم باصدار الحكم على
المتهم في حال ثبوت التهمه فالندم هنا
موضوع هام يؤثر على نوعيه الحكم لاحقا وفي
هذه الحاله فان دونالد ترامب ليس ما يبحث
عن الندم ومن المرجح ان يكون ثابتا في هذا
وسيدافع عن نفسه بقوه وسنرى كم سيستمر على
هذا اذا مجرت ادانته وواجه عقوبه السجن
فقد يغير لهجته عند ذاك
ما الذي تعتقد انه قد تغير في الولايات
المتحده في هذا الصدد يعني هل هي طبيعه
الرؤساء الامريكيين هي طبيعه الرئاسه في
الولايات المتحده ام انما تغير هو الراي
العام ومنظور الامريكيين لمثل هذه القضايا
هذا سؤال هام جدا عندما كان هاردينج مرشحا
رئاسيا عام 1920 كان الجو العام مختلفا
تماما كان الحزب الجمهوري حزبا حقيقيا اما
اليوم فالحزب الجمهوري لم يعد حزبا يشبه
الاحزاب انه اليوم اشبه بمجموعه من
المعجبين كطائفه او فرقه دينيه تتبع
دونالد ترامب وليس كما كانت الاحزاب عليه
عام 1920 ما تغير هو انه عندما تم انتخاب
دونالد ترامب عام 2016 فان الجمهوريين
الذين كانوا قادرين على الوقوف في وجهه لم
يقوم بذلك كانوا يخشون خسران قاعدته
الانتخابيه وبالتالي خسران نفوذهم
وسلطاتهم وقد تنازلوا له دوما لدرجه ان
الحزب قد اصبح شبه طائفه وهذا فارق كبير
بينما نحن عليه الان وما كان عليه الامر
قبل 100 عام
كما تهم لا يزال يتهم بانه يتحدث عن
النساء بطريقه مخله
للحياه مخله بالاعراف كما يقال لم يسمع
الامريكيون شيء مماثل حتى من في قضيه
مونيكا لويسكي هل تعتقد ان المجتمع
الامريكي قد اصبح مع مرور الزمن اكثر
تساهل مع الرؤساء الامريكيين في هذه
القضايا
لا اعتقد انها تاييد لحريه الفكر والعمل
اعتقد انها فجاجه هي فجاجه دخلت في
سياساتنا وقد بدات مع اولئك المذيعين من
الذين يطلقون النكات القاسيه وعندما دخلت
ترامب الانتخابات كان اسلوبه هو الهجوم
على الاخرين بفجاجه وفضاضه ووصفهم اوصافا
قاسيه
هناك فضاضه في سياساته وقد دخل ذلك في
ساساتنا بشكل عام لم يكن ذلك عاما ولم يقم
الرئيس بايدن بشيء من هذا القبيل ونحن
نامل ان نخرج من هذا كله يوما ولكنها
فضاضه على اي حل
لقد ذكرتن واخرين وما من شك ان لرؤساء
غراميات وقد عرف جون كندي بذلك وحتى
كانت معه خليلته ولم يكن ذلك معروفا
للعامه عندها ولكن الوقاحه في حال دونالد
ترامب تختلف عن ذلك كله ولو علم الناس بما
كان من ذلك كله في حياه اولئك رؤساء لمن
انتخبوهم او اعادوا انتخابهم
والنار حفظ
يعني الوصف الذي استخدمته وانت في موضوع
ترامب بوصف قوي انما ما الذي يجعل المجتمع
الامريكي اكثر تقبلا لمثل هذه التصرفات
التي وصفتها انت بهذه الاوصاف التي قد
يقال انها قاسيه
احوال العالم المختلفه هناك الازمه
الماليه عام 2008 وقد ادت الى وصول حكومات
استبداديه الى سده الحكم وبدا الناس
يميلون الى هذا النوع من الحكومات وقد كان
في الولايات المتحده دوما تيار من التسلط
ولكنه تيار قوي جدا الان وهو نابع من شعور
الناس بعدم الامان ويزيد وباء كوفيد من
الطين بالله وكل ذلك يزيد من قوه التيار
الاستبدادي ونتيجه لذلك لدينا ما يصفه
الناس بالقبليه حيث يقوم الجمهوريون
بمهاجمه الديمقراطيين كاشرار وديمقراطيون
يقومون بشيء نفسه اننا منقسمون الان كما
لم نكن من قبل ان الازمات المتلاحقه في
العالم قد ادت الى ذلك كله ليس في
الولايات المتحده فقط بل في اجزاء اخرى من
اوروبا ايضا
كان ذلك المؤرخ الرئاسي جيم روبينولد عوده
اليك براين كراولي الان
فيتش عندما تحدث روندي سانتس عن اخلاقيات
صور نفسه هو كانه اعلى شانا في اخلاقياته
من دون درامب في ولايه كافلوريدا هل يكترث
الجمهوريون للجانب الاخلاقي سواء فيما
يتعلق بالترامب او
انه بالنسبه الى موضوع الاخلاق لا اعتقد
ان كانوا يرون ذلك اهتماما والا لما فازت
رمز العام 2016 اصلا اعتقد ان ما حصل في
2016 حين ننظر الى انتخابات الحزب
الجمهوري كانت ثوره ضد الجمهوريين
التقليديين لهذا جابوش الذي حسب كثيرون
انه سوف يفوز خسرا الان حين ننظر الى راند
سانتوس ودونل
ترامبس متزوجه ثلاثه اولاد وكاثوليكي مؤمن
يحاول ان يكون تقليديا في كل ما له علاقه
بالامور الدينيه والاخلاقيه بعكس ترامب
والناخبون يعرفون ذلك وبالرغم من ذلك
كثيرون منهم يدعمون ترامب في صوره اساسيه
لانه
يقف في وجهه النظام دائما من يوجه اليهم
تهام
يحبهم الناس حين يواجهون الحكومه
الفيدراليه واعتقد ان جائحه كورونا قد
عززت ذلك وهذا ما
يحاول او تحاول حمله جابوش وروندا ان تفعل
ذلك على عكس ترامب لانهم يحاولون ان
يظهروا ان الناس تعبت من الحكومه تعبت من
تدخل الحكومه وسوف نقف ضد ذلك
ويبدو ان الايه قد انقلبت كما يقول بعض
الامريكيين في الوضع العرقي الامريكي وصف
الرئيس السابق وهو ابيض المدعي في نيويورك
وهو اسود بانه عنصري الى اي مدى يجد
القضاء الامريكي نفسه تحت المجهر اذا
نتيجه السجلات الامريكيه بشان الرئيس
الخامس والاربعين دون ترامب في واشنطن
العاصمه عند نصب الرئيس السادس عشر ابراهم
لينكن الذي تعود الامريكيون حقا او باطلا
على نسب الفضل اليه في تحرير العبيد
الامريكيين عند نصبه كنت قد التقيت كلا من
رائد جرار مسؤوله العلاقات الحكوميه في
منظمه الديمقراطيه الان للعالم العربي
وكمال نعواش محامي وخبير قانوني وهو معتمد
لدى المحكمه العليا الامريكيه وهو كذلك
ناشط في الحزب الجمهوري
هل تغيرت القيم في المجتمع الامريكي لدرجه
انه بين رئيس جمهوري ابراهام لينكن ورئيس
جمهوري اخر دونالد ترامب المجتمع اصبح
ينظر الى هذه الامور بشكل مختلف الاحتمال
هناك التغير بالتاكيد هناك اختلافات ما
بين رؤيه الشعب الامريكي لشخصيات تكاد
تكون مقدسه يعني مؤهله مثل لينكن او فانك
فاذرز يعني الاباء المؤسسين والرؤساء
الحديثين ولكن هناك عده فضائح حصلت خلال
العقود السابقه فضائح جنسيه فضائح سياسيه
حصلت لرؤساء امريكيين اخرين اعتقد بان
الفضيحه الحاليه للرئيس ترامب هي ضمن حدود
يعني متوقع من الشعب الامريكي بالتاكيد
كانت هناك بعض التفاصيل الصادمه مما يحصل
مع الرئيس ترامب هو الاول رئيس يقوم تقوم
محكمه امريكيه بالتوجيه تهم ضده هناك يعني
بعض التحديثات ولكن بصوره عامه لا اعتقد
بان هناك صدمه شعبيه كمان اعواش انت كرجل
قانون يعني نسمع في خضم هذه السجلات
الامريكيه الحاليه نسمع من الجمهوريين
مثلا في مساله محاكمه قولا معناه انه لا
احد فوق القانون حتى ان كان رئيس سابق
نسمع من الجمهوريين عكس ذلك بان هذه
ملاحقه سياسيه
وليست هناك ارضيه قانونيه حقيقيه لهذه
المحاكمات ما رايك انت في الموضوع انا
بشوف فيه من
سياسيا اول اشي كان عندك اثنين مدعي عام
شافوا نفس القضيه ورفضوا الى حكوها او
يتابعوها اولا عندك كان المدعي العام
الفرالي شاف هذه المعلومات قبل بسنتين
وقرر انه ما في كفايه انه نتابع
قبل نيويورك قبل اشهر قبل ما اجى هذا
المدعي العام الجديد الاسود اللي قبله
حكينا ما عنا كفايت معلومات انه نتابع هذا
الرئيس سوفي منه في منه شويه يعني العطفا
على ما تفضلت به الان ان
هو امريكي من اصول افريقيه يعني معروف ان
السود الامريكيين يعني الاعداد السوداء
الامريكيين الذين يحاكمون وتتم ادانتهم
ويتم الحكم عليهم بعقوبه في السجن كبير
جدا نفس الشيء بالنسبه لاقليات اخرى في
المجتمع الامريكي يعني هل هناك ارضيه
للقول بانه في المجتمع الامريكي اذا كانت
لديك اموال لتقاوم بها التهم كما هو الشان
بالنسبه
فتفعل ذلك وبالتالي
النظام القضائي كله الان على المحك في هذه
القضيه في الولايات المتحده اول اشي
النقطه الاولى اللي حكيتها ان اكثر الناس
اللي بينسجنوا في امريكا سود
هذا مش معناته انه في عنصريه ضدهم اكثر
الجرائم في امريكا اللي بتقدمها السود
عندك سود بيجو 13% من عدد سكان امريكا
بستين في الميه من الجرائم بيجي من هذا
الشعب وهذا اشي طبيعي انه اكثر الناس اللي
بينسجنوا في امريكا يكونوا سود
ورائد ما رايك يعني
النقاط خلافيه جدا يعني حقيقه حتى حتى
يعني مناقشه
قضيه انه الشخص حاليا المدعي العام هو
اسود هي نقطه غير لائقه قانونيه في
الولايات المتحده يعني سواء كان ابيض او
اسود هناك عده
يعني نظام مؤسسيا امريكي المفروض انه يمنع
شخص ابيض او اسود من ان يقوم باتخاذ
اجراءات عنصريه انا لا اعتقد بان يعني
المدعي العام سواء كان ابيض او اسود له اي
علاقه يعني يعني لون بشرته لها علاقه
بالقضيه فيعني ما اعتقد القضيه لائقه بس
النقاط الاخرى هي نقاط يعني يتم الرد
عليها خلال سنوات طويله يعني في المجتمع
الامريكي بالتاكيد يعني في عنصريه هائله
جدا داخل الولايات المتحده ضد السود وضد
يعني الاقليات في الولايات المتحده حقيقه
انه السود يعني موجودين في السجون باعداد
اكبر وحقيقه انهم في عندهم جرائم اكثر من
الباقين متصله بالعنصريه ضد السوداني
اعتقد هذا النقطه اكبر من النحل الحلقه
الحاليه يعني هناك مئات من الباحثين اللي
اثبتوا بطريقه علميه بانه هناك عنصريه
واضح جدا ضد السد في الولايات المتحده
يعني لا نحتاج لاثبات الان انما كمال
نعواش يعني بصرف النظر عما اذا كان
الفنبراج اسود او ابيض بصرف النظر عن
اعداد السود في السجون الامريكيه يعني
معروف قاعده تقريبا كو انه في اي مجتمع
لمن له المال طبعا
القانون قد ينطبق عليه بطريقه تختلف عن
طريقه انطلاقه على عامه الشعب هل الولايات
المتحده استثناء لهذه القاعده اسمها اول
شيء اللي بتحكيه في الميه اي مطرح في
العالم يعني اذا طلعت اليوم على الطاوله
اللي كان قاعد عليها ترامب كان معه حوالي
اربع خمس محاميين معه
بس من اذا واحد بده يحط مستقبله تحت محكمه
وتحت حكم غيره احسن مطرح في العالم تكون
هو في امريكا لانها اكثر بلد فيها عدل هي
فيها امريكا اذا انت ما معك مصاري هم
بحطوا لك محامي كمثال بس من ناحيه اذا
اتسالت تسالني اذا المعاه مصاري نسبه في
الميه للنجاح اعلى من المعاش مصاري مليون
في المئه هذا الاشي ما رايك انت في نسبه
او مستوى
بالنسبه لك كافه الشعب في الولايات
المتحده بصرف النظر عن الثروه او العرق او
غير ذلك من العوامل رائد يعني بالتاكيد
هناك اشكاليات كبيره بالنظام القضائي
الامريكي اشكاليات عنصريه اشكاليات مثل ما
تفضلت بالمستوى المادي يعني الفقراء ليس
لديهم نفس الامكانيات للدفاع عن انفسهم
مثل الاغنياء فبالتاكيد هناك اشكاليات
هناك امكانيات للدفاع عن النفس داخل
النظام الامريكي هناك عده دول في العالم
انظمتها القضائيه احسن من الولايات
المتحده عده دول انظمتها القضائيه اسوا من
الولايات المتحده ساعتقد في الولايات
المتحده النقطه التي نمر بها حاليا ان
النظام القضائي هو تحت المايكروسكوب تحت
المجهر لان الجميع
سيحاولون التركيز على نقطه هل سيقوم هذا
النظام القضائي
بمحاكمه رئيس سابق بطريقه عادل ام لا
خليني اوضح نقطه واحده يوم انا حكيت ان
لابد ان المصاري لها مش معناته في امريكا
اذا انت معك مصاري وعندك اتهام انك تطلع
منها بدون ما يصير لك اشي نو احنا كل يوم
بنشوف ناس مليونيريه وغنيين
وبتمشكلوا مع الحكومه وبيدخلوا السجن انا
بس بحكي انه النسبه في الميه ممكن تزيد
اكثر يعني قضيات الجنائيه او قضيئات
المدنيه صعبات كثير ويوم عندك اكثر من راس
اكثر من محامي يساعدك النسبه في الميه
اعلى انك تنجح طيب تعال نعود الى القضيه
المباشره وهي مثول ترامب في المحكمه
ولائحه الاتهام التي وجهت اليه يعني نسمع
من بعض الجهات في الولايات المتحده
بانه
العداله للاغنياء تحديدا لرامب لانه لديه
قدرات ماليه تختلف عن بقيه الشعب
قد يجادل بانه هيئه المحلفين انه القرار
لم او الملاحقه لم تتم من قبل هيئه المحلف
امين قبل الملاحقه تمت من قبل ارض براج
ولكن من صوتوا على قائمه الاتهام هم هيئه
المحلفين الذين يمثلون عينات من المجتمع
الامريكي من الانسان الامريكي العادي
خليني اخرى اوضح اخرى نكته ثانيه من ناحيه
هذا السؤال امراه مش معناته انه بس اذا
معك مصاري انه يكون
اصعب هلا عندك واحد زيدان ترامب في مدينه
نيويورك عندك مدينه نيويورك تقريبا 80% من
عدد سكان فيها بعتبروا نفسا الديمقراطيين
او شماليين
وبعكس
هدول المحلفين اللي بدهم يجي يحكموا ضده
راح يجيبوا 12 بني ادم من المجتمع بس انت
عندك مجتمع
كرساله عام بيكرهوا هذا الشخص
وبين انه بيكرهوه اكثر من مره يوم ما
صوتلو لرئيس وهي كانت بلده بيطلعوا
مظاهرات ضدهم دائما اذا انت معك مصاري
معناه مصالحك مرات اسوا الاشي ماذا عنك
انت رائد يعني معروف انه ديمقراطي سياسيا
ليس قضائيا يقول ولكن في النهايه هيئه
المحلفين التي صوتت لصالح قائمه الاتهام
يعني هذه الهيئه فيها عينات من الشعب
الامريكي في نيويورك هل هذا الكلام دقيق
معناته انه هذه الهيئه فيها قد يكون فيها
ديمقراطيون قد يكون فيها جمهوريون قد يكون
فيها مستقلون وبالتالي ما دقه هذا الاتهام
لبراك في تصورك يعني كلامك صحيح هذا
الاتهامات التي تم توجيها للرئيس ترامب هي
مش اتتهامات جاءت من شخص واحد يعني لديه
اجنده سياسيه هذا هذا وسط غير دقيق هناك
بالتاكيد هيئه محلفين اختيار هيئه
المحلفين هو نظام معقد جدا انا كمواطن
امريكي ادخل في يعني هيئه محلفين مره كل
سنتين وعمليه الاختيار هي عمليه دقيقه جدا
اي احد لديه افكار يعني قويه جدا او واضحه
جدا بالنسبه للدول ترامب لن يتم اختياره
سواء كان مساند او معارض لتروم لن يتم
اختياره في ايه المحلفين يتم اختيار
شخصيات ليست لديها مواقف حاده فبالتاكيد
يعني هيئه المحلفين هي يعني مثال على او
يعني بيان واضح بان القضيه هي ليست مسيسه
مئه بالمئه
كان ذلك كلا من رائد جرار وكمال نعواش
انتهت الحلقه اشكر ضيفي معي هنا في بام
بيتش
[موسيقى]